to actually create a profitable course  what i would consider a bad way or a  hard way would be selling something like  drop shipping for amazon that's in there  done that people have been doing it  forever and so trying to sell a course  on that now it's a very very polluted  space as lots of competition the water  is bloody on the flip side you could  still sell a course but you could do it  on how to become a blockchain developer  that's going to be still the same  vehicle of business but the opportunity  that we're pursuing is growing it has  people who have money who want to pay  for it there's a pain and a clear need  and the best part is people are easy to  target and so that's why i would pick a  second one rather than the first